[Music]
chris is in springfield missouri hey
chris welcome to the ramsey show
hey dave this is a honor to be on the
show here well thank you how can we help
i got i i want to know your opinion on
uh
okay
i bought at my first house last summer
me and a couple friends
renovated it according to my realtor
we increased the value by about 50 grand
and i have
some aspirations to become a small time
landlord
i was wondering if it's a totally dumb
idea
to
get a heloc on my current house
for a down payment for a second house
and turn the first one into an airbnb or
a rental yeah
chris how old are you
26. good for you cool and what do you do
for a living i'm a plumber good okay so
when you say we did this renovation do
we own the house or you own the house
and your friends help you with
renovation
i own the house and they helped yes so
it's completely in your name
yes and the house is worth how much
roughly 160
after the fact
and so you think you could sell it for
160 and you owe like 110.
i owe about a hundred grand about 100
okay so you got about 60 equity minus
expenses all right cool
all right
yeah well in fairness as i answer the
question when i was
to tell you who's answering the question
when i was uh
23
24 years old i started buying and
selling real estate
using the nothing down
real estate techniques
that were promising back 35 years ago
they're the same ones that are out there
floating around today telling you to buy
real estate and get rich in real estate
and so i didn't have any money i started
buying real estate i started borrowing
all the money to buy all the real estate
i got rich
by the time i was your age at 26 i had
four million dollars worth of real
estate starting from nothing
and i had over a million dollar net
worth
the problem was i had no idea
the influence of debt on that situation
and i was flipping houses that's what i
was doing i was fixing them and flipping
them
i actually hired crews to do it i know
how to swing a hammer but i was choosing
to do more volume than my hammer would
do by itself and so i just would set up
a crew or hire a painter or hire a
plumber or whatever to get the different
rehab things done on the houses i was
fixing and flipping some of them i was
holding as rentals and so i tell you all
of that to tell you i aspired
at that time to do what you aspire to do
now it's what i wanted to be is what you
want to be fair enough
yes
what happened was the bank got sold that
i was dealing with to another bank
and they looked over and saw that they
they felt like this 26 year old kid owed
them too much money and they called our
notes and we spent the next two and a
half years of our life fighting through
severe banking technicalities that i
didn't even know existed and losing
everything that we owned
we were sued we were foreclosed on and
finally we were bankrupt
at the bottom of that i started studying
how money works
and i started talking to old rich people
i didn't want to talk to young rich
people i had been him i didn't want his
advice it didn't work
and old rich people started telling me
this thing called common sense
and as a christian i started studying
the bible and it talks negatively about
debt 100 of the time
and so i figured out that this debt
thing didn't work and i started buying
my i bought my first piece of real
estate after that with cash it took me a
little while
because it's hard to get the cash
together
and you made some quick you made some
quick easy money plus or minus your
sweat in this house
but it's been fairly quick and it feels
like you could do it all the time well i
did it a lot
i did it a lot
but it still came crashing down around
my ears so that's the guy you're talking
to
he not only wanted to do what you're
talking about but he did it
and i did it with debt and it backfired
on me and it wasn't that i was stupid it
was that debt is stupid
and so all of that to answer your
question and say no
i would not borrow on a heloc to go buy
a rental
i would keep working like a crazy man as
a plumber i'd get this house paid off if
you're going to live in it
or i would sell it and take 50 060 000
and buy a tiny little cheap something
and flip it
with cash
and if you want to do some flips with
cash i'm in i'm fine with that
especially where you're swinging a
hammer and some of your buddies are
doing the renovation with you and that
kind of stuff that's all cool but i'll
tell you now i own
that was 35 years ago that we crashed 30
years ago that we crashed 35 years ago
that
story started
and uh today i own several hundred
million dollars in real estate the
building i'm sitting in is worth 100
million
and so uh and it's all paid for 100 i do
not borrow money for anything ever
after that experience so
i tell you a big long story to give you
a really solid no
don't do that
yeah you know i love the point you make
he's a young guy and if he's not living
in that house
flip that
and and get an apartment yes sir i don't
mind you renting and flipping sir but
pay cash that's right okay he's off to a
good start there if he flips that now
yeah and it's good time to make a little
money if you can get in one of the deal
very difficult to find a deal right now
yeah
like i'm almost impossible needle now
hey i was shocked at how how much that
house cost yeah but um but you can do
that and it's possible in springfield
missouri i mean that's a it's a great
market
and i i want you to go live your dream i
don't want you to let it turn into a
nightmare and it has for me oh and by
the way there was a whole bunch of
people did nothing down real estate then
i was actually in a nothing down real
estate club
back then chris that had 150 members
let me tell you how many of those guys
are still doing real estate deals with
nothing down
zero let me tell you how many of those
guys went broke
all of us
all of us
all of us went broke
no one made it out using that technique
now i do know one guy started selling
the properties off taking the equities
and paying off the others he ended up
with a portfolio about one-third the
size of his original portfolio did
downgrade about 70 percent but turned
out with cash he went the other way from
the nothing down to 100 debt free and
he's still managing those properties i
ran into him the other day but the guys
that persisted with this nothing down
bull crap stuff that sold in these
weekend seminars
100 failure rate a decade later two
decades later so i want to stay there
dave because it's still being sold and
it's being glamorized on social media oh
big time so what's what are they not
telling them
they're telling you oh you can do all
this but there's something they're not
telling they're not properly portraying
the risk
what's the what's the hidden information
they're not sharing the nothing down
deal only works if everything goes
perfect and nothing ever goes perfect
that's it
risk
debt equals risk more debt equals more
risk
if you owe a hundred thousand dollars on
on something that's a lot more risk than
if you owe one thousand dollars on that
thing
so more debt equals more risk 100 of the
time because you've got to carry it if
it doesn't sell you got to carry it if
the fed decides to jack up rates oh wait
that happened you got to carry it if
there's a pandemic oh wait that happened
you got to carry it even if you lose
your job because of the pandemic oh you
got to carry it even if there's hyper
inflation so it freezes the market like
a deer in the headlights oh these are
real freaking things that happen
and they happen to me you got to carry
it if the president changes the tax
legislation and changes and flips all
investment property on its head ronald
reagan completely destroyed the real
estate market while i was in the middle
of it i'm a ronald reagan fan but worst
presidential decision he made completely
undid the investment real estate market
by flipping the
uh
flipping the uh depreciation schedules
off
changing the value of real estate with
one stroke of the pin and it turned it
turned the snl business on its head back
then the savings and loan industry and
you can't control that crap because
you're not the president
and it it affects
things out of your control come in and
and
make you stupid when it's stress tested
always reveals itself to be stupid you
can tell it was skinny dipping when the
tide goes out
that's what they don't know